when people think of salt marshes they
usually think of the grasses the birds
and animals but people don't always
think about the smallest creatures
living there as scientists try to
measure the environmental impact of the
world's largest accidental oil spill
some are studying the smallest animals
namely the arthropods near the bottom of
the food chain arthropods are animals
like insects spiders and crustaceans and
the food web they form is a vital
component of this ecosystem more than
200 million gallons of oil gushed into
the Gulf of Mexico and some of that oil
crept into the marshes of the Gulf Coast
contaminating hundreds of miles of
coastline from tar balls to thick oil a
team from the University of Houston
conducted a study looking at the coastal
food web along the Gulf and the Atlantic
coast last year before the spill now the
researchers hope they can shed light on
the oils impact on that food web so we
have 22 sites and at each site we make a
collection of the arthropod food web and
we do this by vacuum sampling so we have
a backpack with a lawn mower engine on
it and it connects to a big hose and
what Pennings team visit the site from
Texas to New England carefully surveying
an animal in plant health at Brittany
DeLoach McCall sucks up arthropods at
this collection site in New Jersey her
colleagues checked the marsh grass and
look for other small animals a food web
consists of a variety of species that
play different roles so there's plants
which are eaten by a variety of insects
that eat plants would call those
herbivores and then they're eaten by
other things predators like spiders with
reference to the oil spill it might be
that some members of this food web are
more vulnerable to oil than others by
taking light readings from under the
marsh grass taking cores of the roots
and counting snails and other critters
the team can get a health snapshot by
comparing oiled and annoyed areas that
get an idea of the impact in this case
we're likely to see that the oil would
affect more than just one or two species
but might affect you know a large
proportion and so that could perturb the
food web in in novel ways the team
sampled five heavily oiled sites they
added some locations
- since their locations were not heavily
loyal the team filed a dramatic
difference and Marsh is affected by the
crude in the oiled sites we saw a lot of
dead plant material we saw a lot of mud
flats where the plants have died and
been eroded away we also saw a lot of
oiled crabs and snails and not it didn't
seem like as many insects as in control
plus the current year of this study is
funded through the National Science
Foundation Pennings hopes to continue
his research to monitor any long-term
impact of the spill and while some
scientists say much of the oil has
already broken down marshes are prone to
long-term contamination the nature of a
salt marsh is that the sediments retain
organic matter for a very long time and
decomposition is very slow what that is
likely to mean is that the small animals
that live in the marsh whether they're
fiddler crabs or insects are likely to
be exposed to oil for decades to come
penning says he will focus on tracking
this effect to learn more about the
marsh food web and help understand the
oils impact